what's up fool yeah man what's up what's
up fo podcast how's everybody doing
we're back hell yeah from a long
week we were in West Palm Beach West
Palm Beach it was humid over there
soaking up the Sunray by the pool it was
humid but it was more humid with Adam
Murray in the
room there with Adam Murray from Orlando
he's the guy with two little curs the
one up from the Facebook video the one
you guys thought little like Hacksaw Jim
dug Jake The Snake Jr he's Jake The
Snake rubert rubert rubbert rert he's
rert
Murdoch he wish he's
rert pumpkin bro
comedian hey bro you think I just th th
my tape in
two this fo dog you're trying to find
out who the producer to the your show
was too dog send a real this guy first
of all man we got to get a e fund going
for to get him luggage man because can
laundry baset two two gigs already I
think Fort
Lauderdale Tampa and now this gig here
in um West Palm Beach and this fool
shows up with a hamper with clean
clothes that a hamper a hamper good
baskets e a laundry basket pretty much
of clean clothes and he carries all his
um he made his back seat he put a big
pole like for cloth hanger it like a
closet that where he hangs all his dress
shirts it's wardrobe this guy like a
pride
investigator yeah he's L just jump in
anywhere Oh Hey where's that was a
Target hold on man let me get my red
t-shirt and start shoplifting jack of
all trades master of none
yeah man he treats that c a
cab [__] uh [__] travel partner
over here dog yeah man he look like the
a dude that's too old to go to
Raves yeah he wear those baggy pants
that like he just like n they're baggy
pants huh like jko from the 990s dog hit
the long
arms [__] scraped the floor and [__]
showed up with dirt weed again oh my god
dude [__] that weed dog man that weed
was so bad he didn't even smoke it he's
like you guys going at it I'm like
[__] touching that
[__] [__] dude you know his weed look
like his weed look like those um those
those
round prickly thing that fall off trees
[__] uh Pine con pine pine cone yes
pine cone weed has that pine cone weed
[__] how about that night he took off
his socks F and his shoes almost [__]
gag dog oh yeah man F took off his socks
it was it was a Thursday socks from
driving all
day that's a 4-Hour driving sock
yeah smell like Mexican cheese dog no
man it's more smell more like um monter
Yak that's he looks like a
yak looks like he drinks cockroach
milk they do that now right yeah it's
[__] gross who would do that how
broke do you have to be that came on the
news though that R out coconut I mean
not sorry coconut cockroach milk is good
yeah they're it's trendy now on Twitter
like mosquito blood myself [__] z i
could somebody just go how man is there
really an ant
man is there really a Ant Man where's
roach man at dog oh man so we flew out
to this a we flew out to West Palm Beach
and um me I have Amazon Prime so I
downloaded I I bought I rented Superman
versus Batman or Batman versus Superman
and then we get on the plane and that
[__] moves for free I hate it it dog
I let of good movie work for free on
that plane huh yeah F there was a lot of
[__] on that that was badass dog but I
slept dog [__] thaty I had a
dream I know man you you were were you
comfortable on the way there yeah it was
cool dog not on the way back dude I had
that big ass [__] Amazon [__]
creature next to me dog the tro got a
hot ass leg a hot ass arm and a hot ass
body dog me know on the way there man it
was nobody sitting next to me I thought
he' be yeah but then this little old
lady showed up bro okay right his cool
man it's Pearl she was small bro she
look a old ass softball
coach I about that one time we went to
that big old brother like he's like
looking for a seat and he sat right next
to you that big ass fool you don't
remember yeah and then switched oh my
god dude that fool was big dog he was
big dude I said you know what I'm going
to go sit in that eye over there how's
the movie though Superman versus uh it
sucked yeah like suck you like all that
comic book [__] huh I do but this one
sucked that bad fool it sucked dude and
and also I saw on the way back home I
saw Civil War um think Civil War Marvel
or American Captain America it was all
right man but too much fighting didn't
didn't get to the story I really like
Ant-Man I didn't know that fool get
large hell yeah man into he's the best
character in the whole show yeah dude
you see the movie yet yeah [__] no I
haven't seen at man oh you guys I wait
for incredible ho to show
up there not much to do out there man at
the at the West Palm Beach but we weren
swimming over every day yeah except for
the last day it was cool though the pool
we were the ones there with the brown
bodies a lot of people that pale ass
kids huh pale ass fools dog translucent
fools there some dude some badass
Confederate flag shorts though yeah hey
fool I saw a dude with the confeder FR
shirt too dog but it is a South right
that's a South it's a South South will
rise again not wonder they so at Walmart
probably probably fool [__] it that's
truck shop truck stop Clothing dog cuz
got to buy something [__] Rebels you
know couple of shout outs here for Eric
Torres give us some gas dog Eric Torres
shout out to you man from your big
brother Edgar Torres Edgar raised Eric
until he got married wow so he's like a
son Eric is leaving to the Army on
September 12 the day after September 11
and Edgar wants you to know that he
loves you and he'll miss you stay safe
out there yeah man run
Forest Orlando Maldonado he don't just
play Bongos who listens to our podcast
on Mondays because that's the the day
that he hates the most and the show
helps him get by without slapping the
[__] out of his
BS well I'm glad I'm glad our show helps
you not slap the [__] out of your BX
turn him into a pacifist just do your
job bro don't worry about that fool
don't be peeing in his coffee
cup or that that one there was a a news
today um somebody at a I don't know if a
d Dunkin Donuts or or was a coffee shop
this guy put some
methamphetamines and some THC instead of
a police officer's coffee damn at
Starbucks or some [__] oh no Dunkin
Donuts Dunkin Donuts [__] that's a salt
fool hell yeah man dude that dude's
going to be in big trouble dog hell yeah
man that's [__] up but you know what
not he's luy he has one broken rib right
now in jail
hey dog but did that cop how did the cop
find out we get all [__] up on the
road came back for another
one give me a double I never thought
about that now but um there's people
that could come at you like that now oh
dude they especially like if they want
revenge yeah dude that's how the [__]
oh man you know what man I know I know
this coping has nothing to do with it
but I'm going just [__] put a booger
in his hamburger that F will never find
out that was a tasty burger they W found
out because it's just the one little
booger inside inside a hamburger nothing
going to happen I'm pretty sure that
that's what happens when they when they
um when they process meat like if like
it's a lot of just like you have 5,000
lbs of meat but um 10 PBS in 10 lbs of
[__] got in are we going to stop
production for those 10 pounds no we're
going to cover up with more meat oh yeah
dude unless somebody gets sick [__] it
send them a chat there meat there like
particle [__] particles and meat when it
get processed has to be right dude
supposedly there's [__] rats in there
and they run around and [__] on the meat
mice and all that [__] dog so you have
that in there dog oh man just cut that
[__] off and [__] keep the [__]
bulk rolling I'm just going to go
hunting bro [__] easy who else goes
hunting right now I don't know the
powerful Joe Rogan oh wow he goes
hunting yeah for real dog with a bow and
arrow and all that [__] so he P hunting
and he save that meat all year or in a
freezer yeah n fool I guess that's the
only meat that fool eats dog so Mo moose
and elk and [__] like that I mean [__] I
never had dinner at the Rogan household
dog I don't know but I mean for what I
he hunts and then he he U he saves his
own food yeah all that [__] he just I
guess he was going to go vegetarian or
some [__] now he's [__] all the meat
he eats is he's hunting we don't have
supermarkets or what I guess not but I
guess that way you to do it man I will
say that um if you're not vegan like I'm
vegan I don't need meat you know but if
I were to not be vegan I think I would
go that way that route you know hunt my
own meat that's the only way you fresh
it's warm there's no there's no
chemicals in it or I would get my own
fish free rain yeah dude get my own fish
cuz another farm salmon now like they
have Farms where salmon just grow and
they never swim up River that's why they
don't they don't get as as Pink as the
other one no you just have them rotating
in the [__] little pool dog like that
that's how they swim and all that [__]
like that meat dude you don't know where
it comes from that's in your Supermarket
I mean dick even the stuff at Whole
Foods dog where does it really come from
dog Bolivia There You Go fool and then
they put [__] on the meat so it doesn't
get all brown faster dude I know fo that
works at Stater Brothers he's a butcher
and [__] they treat it with [__] damn
isn't that crazy fool I mean [__] uh
you know not that that fool was supposed
to tell me but that's what they do
though McDonald's going to go um
healthier on the chicken nuggets now
yeah yeah dude start using real
chicken because before they use toenails
and um the beaks and carage right and
all the leftover me like the edges of
stuff the byproducts the byproducts and
then just make it all in one little um
one little meat batter like milk and
then just make the cut them out just
squeeze them out hey man they tast good
though huh hell yeah do give what the
[__] they do with they man it's just
sugar huh they mix suar everything good
ref Su they're going to stop putting
less sugar in the buns too well that's
other thing that you guys uh were
talking about the other day in the car
when we came back from the airport I
didn't know that I'm F I always knew
that the I didn't know you read that
book sweet Forks Over Knives when I read
Forks Over Knives and then another book
called The omnivores dilemma the
omnivores dilemma in that book they
break down the history of breakfast and
why here in America like think about it
man somehow here in America we went it
went viral that we have to eat eggs and
sausage every morning it's an industry
fo it's an industry right but we're
programmed to do that yeah well dick I
mean look at all the [__] places or
or for the people who don't want to eat
eggs and sausage Like Only in America
give weed [__] say let's eat a bowl
of the delicious sweet sugar crisp
cereal yeah dude [__] no one else does
that huh [__] no we're addicted to
refined sugar dog I love cereal though
man what's up well that's what get you
coming back dog when I was little when I
was living myself like right after I
wasn't living by my mom's F I used to
you know how we used to eat at my house
dog you were there two fried eggs or
three fried eggs over easy and then the
first one I make breaks I throw that
[__] in the
trash D [__] that [__] going to be my
mom something and then eat
it I would make sure the pan is nice bro
then I would just put some butter and
then flip that [__] over gently
and then cook another egg gently flip it
over and three eggs with some [__]
beans and queso fresco C cheese or
vanilla on top jalapenos like a king and
then after I'm done some Frosted Flakes
with banana okay I have a question for
you all right with cereal you used to
say you love cereal a lot were you one
of those fools that got frosted fakes
Flakes and then put sugar on top too
hell no yeah youed should trip out on
fols sugar diabetic [__] I don't know ja
Luna no but some other fat FY Used to
Know Nam Balto used to do that [__] no
man I will put sugar on cornflakes and I
never liked that either dog I hated it
bro cuz then at the end of the at the
end of the meal you got like sugar water
no sugar milk on the bottom yeah dude
[__] that though that's too much F but I
would hunt my food if I had to what you
what are the what you hunted around here
though well I know I from Hussein
Armando's brother he goes hunting over
here at Hunter leget and then they go to
a couple other places they [__] hunt
Pig they hunt [__]
guotes my brother get pulled over by the
cops on the way back from
hunting about when they took his guns
yeah no what happened was is the house
beat his ass yeah for the house right
there on Echo Park on santin that was
that was Hector's house where he used to
live with his mom so these fools were
out there shooting pigeons with pelet
guns right so somebody called the cop
same was in the late 20s here right yeah
no probably early 30s early 30s and
those other all those fols were in the
early 30s and um he was like 50
something but anyways so somebody called
the cops that these fools had sniper
rifles man so the cops show up and they
[__] cornered off the house they
start they didn't put SWAT on them but
they pointed guns at them everybody exit
out of the house fool they made
everybody come out of the house they
made the mom come out of the house all
the old ladies and then Hector was like
yeah man that's the day my mom got
diabetes e cuz I guess they scared her
scared the diabetes out so then they
pulled everybody out they didn't have a
warrant but they the mom let the cops in
so they took all their [__] rifles
all their handguns they had them all
laid out in the front yard and then they
[__] asked whoin dog all so what do
you do with these
guns
hunting and then the cops all what do
you hunt and that fo said pigs fo the
cop kicked that fo in the ribs
dog kicked him in the ribs kicked him in
the [__] ribs dog
he's you want to keep on getting smarter
I don't know give me a [__] gun I
might kill you [__] dude they
jumped his ass right there and then they
took him in they let him out the same
day and then they took about a week for
them to get their guns back [__] you
know misunderstanding and [__]
misunderstanding bro now now Hector's
mom has
diabetes because the
pigs yeah man he could have just said
whatever right but he said Pig they got
P yeah well he was [__] with them dog
like [__] these guys
e if it was back in the old days
but yeah man he goes hunting so that's
what he gets he gets deer too dog what's
up F also we got a shout out from Dan
from
Vegas at
csbs So
drew7 Lisa
9803 and M seal for giving us some nice
iTune reviews also
man man after we did the show we got a
phone call from ezone who the producer
order there at B real TV oh hell yeah we
went over there and man they weren't
kidding huh hell no we got served
properly F you know some people show up
with dabs this guy show up with slabs oh
dude you see that [__] I mean this guy
show up like when he showed up with that
the slab dab the slab I was like nah
that can't be real that's a a fly
catcher one of those wet you know those
little cement those little um flight
catchers yeah the little [__] Will
They smash them no the little Pap oh the
paper the where stick on they stick fly
paper fly paper there you go but he had
like a whole quar huh no [__] though
that was more dog that was a mean ass
[__] cookie dog it was peanut bread
he took it out the freezer yeah fool
that [__] was big dog dick that was like
fool what 12 x 24 those those guys that
be real TV they're professional dabbers
oh they're not [__] around at a
certain temperature perfect temperature
because if you do it before you can
[__] burn your lungs I didn't know
that just to [__] dab like a [__]
[__] but it was cool dog
I was perfectly dabbed out it's cool man
to see be real TV just hang out and be
be real hell yeah he was being real yeah
real real I didn't know there was bikers
called um seis Hill yeah they had the
little Club dog it was cool little cool
ass jackets and [__] I wanted me a
jacket D they'll probably give you one
fool man we went to we were hanging out
like little kids at a at a Cy store at
um B real TV's office hell yeah dude
it's like a hangout man they have a ball
part where um everybody is happy to see
you hell yeah cool little couch
sometimes you want to know where
everybody knows your name [__] yeah dude
and they're always glad you came you
want to go at be real TV everybody got
dabs for you they got dabs that are big
big enormous oh my God and and normally
like when people I see on TV you on TV
on Instagram you see people do dabs and
that [__] like smoking burning
everything oh yeah falling all over the
but these gu was like and also the
[__] tips right temperature huh yeah
they don't use they don't use ceramic
they don't use glass they use quartz
quartz that's quarts I guess it's a type
of glass that they blow and it's perfect
for dabbing it what Crystal yeah that's
a perfect buy me one and that's a you
know that's how you do it and I never
knew how you do it properly the only the
best dabs we ever had were them and I
think the only other comparable ones
were the ones that Rory used to bust out
I know and and like sometimes I wonder
like who who hits Dabs out of these
$1,600 rigs they do yeah F dukes and
Nobles man they had um they have a case
where they have um you know how some
people collect roaches and they have
like a nice little tiny marijuana roach
Dash man these food have a roach that's
that's like 13 Ines dude [__] big ass
one big old chichin Chong Joints off
yeah a roach but it's 13 in long and
it's burnt like almost all the way
through man like if you were like that
[__] man you will come back to
life I was like thinking about that [__]
man imagine something like a natural
disaster [__] dude in case of emergency
break glass imagine for there's no more
weed in the world left just those
[__] four big ass Road just have to
[__] re we have to burn be real bro
we got to smoke let that [__]
dry up and then smoke hit dashes
probably get high as [__]
um you know that some people have those
smoking tips now to smoke um their
joints they're like made out of glass
and they're real tiny man they had one
here that was bigger than his water a
bottled water here oh dude it was
[__] that tip was bigger than a
bottled water dude it was enormous dog I
was [__] in a
dog you know me dog yeah man when you go
to a place like that place we were
hanging out right after the the last
podcast man you get spoiled man oh for
real dog cuz then you're sitting at W
Palm Beach with Adam Murray
weed he's want to beat the [__] out of
that fool with the
lamp it was crazy we went to what we
hung out our week man it was hot as hell
yeah but it was it was hot dude but not
like as bad as New York or as bad as
Corpus Christie dog we are good crowds
too [__] yeah dude it was [__]
awesome they came to laugh no [__] and a
quick shout out to that dude that uh was
out there with that smoked us out Jose
Garcia and Tony Garcia his cousin thank
you very much over there in West Palm
Beach also a shout out to cheese
delicious dude thank you very much for
coming out to the shows dog and
representing hell yeah cheese delicious
yeah man this week this week let
everybody know everybody we're coming to
tucon Arizona so tonight the show
tonight to be at is Tucson
Arizona one night only at TCC Music Hall
okay then tomorrow I'll be in p
California August
13 tomorrow I'll be in pelo Colorado
August 13th one night only at Pueblo
Memorial Hall please spread the word
we're trying to fill these shows up
Tucson Arizona tonight probably Colorado
tomorrow August 12th August 13 please be
there tell all your friends let's fill
this up people come on man spread the
word and all your dreams will come
true
Chicago august 19 and
20 these shows will sell out faster than
you can
say no guest
spots Chicago august 19 and
20 four shows at Joe's on weed Street
tickets are
going ticket are
gone sold out
oh my God chickens are gone for both
Saturday shows but there's still shows
for Friday show if you if you hurry up
oh my God so man you got to get these
tickets at in Chicago or if you can go
to Chicago just come toight T Arizona we
have tickets tonight and prob to
Colorado tomorrow night we got ticket
for that San Jose Improv August 26
through the 28th I'll be at the Improv
I'm also filming my next special there
on Saturday the
27th you could be part of History you
could be on
television you could be in the beginning
of the show if you're a six foot over
six feet
tall and people tell you damn bro you
look [__] crazy dog you're [__]
scary we need you to be at the Improv at
6:00 p.m. so you can film your ass as I
walk into the
show I'm looking for some ugly
[__] just stand in front of the
door scary ugly and scary Thug looking
San
josean San Jose so we're going to have
bird MK standing in the front bro with
his
bird and then that Indian fool bro with
a [__] box well there you go dog and
then we're going to have a couple of
bikers and then after I take my show I'm
I'm digging a filming me taking off with
a motorcade of Beast Cruiser bro and
going down San Jose [__] yeah dude so
man if you if you guys got anybody with
a beast Cru want to cruise with me and
get filmed it'll be after my
show probably at the end of night we're
going to all take off on beach scws
so that's it on that
one also Brea
Improv in Bria California September 1
through the 4th at The Improv
also coming
soon I'm coming to Rhode Island and
Boston September 22nd and 23rd so least
be there cuz I'll be I'll be yelling
out Vol and I'm going need people to
yell at Vol in Rhode Island Boston on
September 22nd and 23rd I need help
promoting those shows since that's not a
big market for me please spread the word
and if you want to help promote by
passing off some flyers and posters to
local businesses we'll give you a few
tickets for helping just email fans at
felipesworld decom for rad Island and
Boston tickets
only I can't believe it I'm GNA be at
the Wilber theater in
Boston hopefully there'll be people
there
this also all shows info can be found on
Philipp world.com also people very
important if you love this podcast
what's so F podcast we're going to need
you guys to subscribe
and get your friends to
subscribe and write a good review
anywhere you can write on a piece of
paper and throw it away whatever you can
do just take the time to write um hey
man this show gets me through the day if
it wasn't for the show I would have
stabbed my boss
already hey this show get me through the
day fing for the show I don't know what
I'll do all day but let us know also
next
week there won't be a
show you guys to subscribe to the show
and let us know if you're listening so
next week no show sh you're going to be
filming huh F
yes I I I I got a I submitted for a row
for a television
show with you guys and I got it what
that's what's up fol I got it I'll be
filming Monday Tuesday and Wednesday so
we wouldn't have to time to do the
podcast the hard work paid off though
hell yeah man I think is that I'm on the
I'm filming that show um super store
[__] yeah dude and on NBC I play a p
easy [__] yeah dude I'll be at the
sunset room next Monday the 15th I'll be
hosting should have I Adam Murray bro oh
yeah he's going to be here yeah [__]
yeah dude I'll give him a spot so yeah
man in a Heights come out free show if
he get a ride back bro Jesus [__]
Christ I'm going to give him a ride to
the [__] donut shop right there and
that's it f drop him off you and your
[__] basket dog keep your shoes on
that feel be weird out over there should
that for bombing he won't bomb just
to yeah bro this this place right here
legendary
man how about what that told us that
finally told us a good story the last
[__] night at 1 in the morning dog
tell tell us dude this [__] ran
into Sandra Bullock he didn't run into
her but he guess he was paintballing and
I got to say who the [__] paintballs
after their [__] 30s Jesus Christ but
anyhow I guess it's in a [__] open
parking lot or whatever so yeah man I'm
coming out there with my friends and I
look over them all
hey man is that Sandra bulck and I guess
she had like [__] bodyguards and the
shooting she s heard Sandra Bullock she
freaked out oh my God oh my God they
jumped in their cars and [__] took
off dude and then I guess this fool put
his [__] paintball [__] away and him
and his little friends took off yeah so
we're on the road man and we see this uh
Pontiac Grand Am and we look over and
it's Sandra Bullock and she looks over
at us and she screams ah and she shoots
cross three lanes and takes the [__] off
damn Jesus Christ dude how much more of
a [__] potential stalker could you
look like he didn't follow her Betty huh
I don't know I don't think he I don't
think he told us the story he probably
did [__] follow the [__] out of there
before I had the long hair and a beard
yeah like that's what was [__]
scaring her dog and that big ass [__]
giant
mug maybe she got scared of because he
was trying to give him give her his 8 by
10 he want to be speed three I'm I'm
Randy quay's
brother this will [__] Adam Murray
dog
hilarious Cars and Coffee oh my God yeah
I think Seinfeld has a show like that
right yeah well he does so what's upful
you think Donald Trump really threatened
to assassinate Hillary Clinton uh well
it's funny that you say that I just read
a [__] um a Twitter um article that
um I forgot what the name of the leader
was in Israel that um in Israel they had
the extreme right they were like
extremist and um I guess the leader at
that time wanted to the I forgot what
the [__] name of the movement was was
to like give a portion back of the land
back to Palestine and [__] and they're
like [__] that so I get oh the leader
now was the one that was leading the
movement and saying [__] in the same
words Donald Trump was saying about
Hillary in the Second Amendment well
that dude ended ended up getting oh the
Oslo Accords uh I think is what it was
but ended up getting assassinated in the
same term even though he didn't say what
he to assassinate her kind of you know
laying it out for [__] Second
Amendment extremist to [__] you know
put a [__] bullet between her eyes I
say I mean it's been said so but it's
dude this fo is just a [__] idiot dog
you're be saying that stupid ass [__]
dog seriously how the [__] we going to
go from a [__] perfect [__]
articulate smart intelligent president
to this [__] piece of [__] but you
know what I think tables are turning and
people are saying that this Fool's just
a [__] idiot dog can't be saying that
[__] dog he's just playing to [__]
you know the sheep and [__] but still
dude come on fool um Donald Trump just
got sponsored by um Red Hot Cheetos
you're lying dog yeah are you serious F
oh I was like about your joke oh looking
like a [__] Cheeto [__] guy though
dude but dude [__] that guy maybe the
same
suits the same ties dog food too man
it's like dude dude that fol just gross
dude the GOP to that's all you got dog
[__] out of here dog anyway and then say
stupid ass [__] about [__] McCain too
it's like dude oh and getting the medal
I always wanted a medal a medal of honor
it's like the [__] dude that's the
people some the people who have the
Medal of Honor or purple hearts those
people don't want that to get that that
mean you're going to get hurt yeah they
don't want that [__] and then this
[__] idiot dude really dog the [__]
out of here
dog
anyways you know that you have a Wither
of V just give him a
heart a [__] cowardly candidate dude
he should that TR should say if I the
king if I the president or the for
us the [__] dude The Man Behind the I
build the a wall and then I'll make
America greater If I Only Had a Brain
yeah dude and then the other thing too I
will shut up a baby oh dude remember
that [__] about the babies dog are you
serious dude let the [__] baby cry or
go down in the [__] audience grab the
little baby Pat him and chill him the
[__] out and continue with your speech
dog this is what made out with that baby
this give a couple kiss remember like
the cartoons show like a a guy running
for office kissing all the babies yeah
for you that's what you shower the P you
know you kiss old ladies you shake hands
and you hug and kiss babies dog this
[__] idiot now no seriously get the
baby out of here really dog come on fool
it's a future right there you're all
shooting them out here [__] punk dog
I don't think Donald Trump never like
directors H oh hell no dude stick to the
scripts sir but it's funny now if you
start seeing his speeches now he's
actually looking down at his notes and
it's messing up his rhythm dude he's
still full of [__] and also the [__] he
said about the judge the Mexican judge
that he's building a wall and he dude
the dude's from Indiana dude he don't
give a [__] about Mexico he's just a
judge dude fair and impartial dude
laying down the law [__] out of here dog
I he ain't going back hell no fool that
fool's Pro American as they come is his
American is nachos and burritos oh and
apple pie yeah man cobbler yeah F please
[__] out of here [__] punk what's
your thoughts on that fool dog on who on
Donald TR Trump Donald
I think if he if he become president a
lot of a lot of commun going to have
good the same material oh yeah and you
know what's funny dude I was talking to
that um the German dude the maintenance
guy that we met at West Palm Beach you
met him first the first night Bernard
yeah he came show I do not understand
these people with their self-
entitlement they go for Trump this is
not a position for people that are
idiots they could put Mickey Mouse right
there and people will vote for him yeah
man J put know about [__] vo a shitty
president oh dude he's like dude oh and
he was talking about driving for that
people don't know how to drive in
America dog especially in Florida in
Germany you go 6 months and here you get
the license in two days two days yes fol
got drive for six months in the Autobon
yeah and that's he's all stupid people
always come up to him and go oh yeah
dude everybody drives recklessly in um
in uh Germany the autoban oh you don't
imagine what it takes to drive an
autoban a lot of skill or that's [__]
anyway you had a y man podcast and I had
a wor fo podcast with that fool yeah
fool he was cool fo cool dog I like the
jokes about the smoking y please me like
dude he was a he had fun dog was fun
fool I pushed my microwave too hard
uhhuh no I pushed my refrigerator too
much and I guess it it disconnected my
television so I have television all
night so the next day I call up the the
front dance I say I need a television no
I need a my TV don't work I don't know
why but I know why so that me and that F
were pushing that the back of the TV
that wooden [__] [__] heavy right
then he plugged it back in and then he
started talking you look very
familiar [__] like like a Gestapo
talking to me very familiar there you go
he goes I'm a comedian oh you do a joke
about insurance ah dick he goes hey you
need insurance like that right right he
goes yeah that's me oh wow what are you
doing here I'm doing a ComEd over there
you want to go yes I'll bring my wife oh
hell yeah went dog [__] pretty wife
too huh fo four of those big old [__]
hands ass he has one of those [__]
hands you [__] with him he'll break your
neck dog he ain't [__] around those
big ass hands bro like he he could be a
heavyweight fighter yeah he has those
Kane Velasquez [__] hands dog he's
[__] mean [__] what they what do
they call [__] those [__] hands
were Jerry rigged yeah
[__] Meo meat hooks dog and black
hair for a German fool yeah fool and he
was talking about like I don't
understand you come here to America and
everybody don't care they're slow I come
from Germany where everything's precise
not five minutes before or after on time
I don't get this he was F he he was
enamored at the stupidity fool and also
of the idiots that are voting for Trump
he did not get it dog he's all he has a
double engineering degree he has two
degrees in engineering dog ain't no fool
dog but in America I push television off
and plug back in it's I am head of
Maintenance he was telling me he getting
[__] he was getting [__] over with the
taxes in Germany oh yeah he was single
not married sing oh they were jacking
him for half his [__] [__] 5 grand he
would got 2500 a month and another thing
he mentioned was across the way they
were building a parking garage really
he's all no American workers there CU
they don't want to work hard all
immigrants all Latino mostly they work
hard they don't care they just want to
get fat of sugar and eat
cookies I swear to God they know bro yes
fo they bro i i e five cookies on the
way over
here I'm a fat pig bro I come home I
feel I'm going to teal myself with sugar
I know fol like I'm out of town it's
hard for me to find vegan food so [__] I
won't eat but if I see a jamb juice
[__] L ass smoothie first time I ate
jumo Juice drink jum juice in a I [__]
up I got that jumbo juice the protein
shake the peanut butter one the peanut
butter one and I told that lady you know
what man it's Friday I R I swam all week
throw some Oreo cookies in there
please that sh was good of course fol
give me a break dog you had Oreo cookies
to anything is delicious full stop the
first time I ever had a like a chocolate
shake with milk and um flavoring and
then they put [__] Oreos in it with
vanilla [__] get that t give me two
of them fol have you ever had Oreo
[__] frosting on a cake in the middle
and on top never oh my God fool you
don't even know you got to find a vegan
one dog I had the Oreo the Oreo pie Oreo
the cookies and cream Oreo pie at
Denny's when they used to have them back
in the day yeah that shit's delicious
and the bottom is made with the brown
the chocolate cookie yes dog that [__]
is Bomb we were eating hot dogs okay at
at JNS hot not JNS at the little hot dog
stand that used to be on santam
Monica and Virgil s Monica and Virgil I
forgot dude I know what you're talking
about I just don't there 71 across the
street and then across the the club
called the garage right there they used
to sell hamburgers and they put a little
fried egg on top with chili before Fat
Burger did it huh yeah they've been
there forever bro they put a they give
you a hot dog bro they give you a
hamburger also with two with a weenie
Slice on top and the Egg and the chili
bro as medicine is that is true your
health that [__] sounds good as [__] do
[__] dude order another one [__]
let's just get two each I was eating
with Mando I was there with I was eating
there with Benny mana and Martin Moreno
and Gabriel GL with f nickeloden or
something right he go where you guys at
man he go over here eating a ea this
burger with the eggs oh [__] I just ate
a Denis you want
pies shows up with three pies hell yeah
let's get back together and then you
know man you know I don't know man like
it's a good feeling back in the days I
know give me the Goosebumps to reminisce
you know like hanging out with Comics
even though I was hanging out with um
Martin Morano and it was Benny mana and
some other Ivan and then we were all
just eating bro and then another comic
goes from n come from somewhere else
[__] it you want to eat pies I was a
really [__] fool bro but [__] it you
know like when you're a kid you pies
[__] no so you sure was three pies one
of them was a Snicker one oh my God the
Snicker one and the the mud pie W and
the Oreo one can I get a big glass of
[__] milk too no no no milk we're
just eating there about on the [__]
um we were eating the pies in the
parking lot bro like a bunch of comics
just coming back from the
road this oh man this is funny story man
you died that day do 2004 you couldn't
even take it 2004 we had just came I
just came back from doing Orlando he
actually came back my mom and we're all
hanging out we're blazing in the back of
the Laugh Factory like
ITW like in the back of Hollywood
Boulevard and we're hanging out we're
just chilling right there in a cough
pass by and then this comedian um his
ComEd Chago he goes hey the cop P was
over we just tell him we're a bunch of
comrades who just came back from the
road you just started dying you took a
knee huff and I couldn't stop laughing
at that [__] man
cuz first of all the cop don't give a
[__] where he came from [__] no and
first of all none of nobody here bought
me just came from the
road I put myself in
there F just trying to put himself in
the
story but D it was hilarious though oh
dude they his story ready oh ready to
let him know dog like those dudes are
like always get pulled over oh yeah I
told him it was a comic and I gave him
my CD and you let me go your Ling ass up
oh you see this comic BR bro if you're
going to [__] speed on speed bro just
[__] put the flyer for your show on
the front of the dashboard you tell the
cop you're
late you're there to do a policeman ball
all right [__] all right Mike
Marino who gives a [__] dude told me
that [__] that was a cop [__] beat
your ass dog just for that [__] that
would be funny man just picture Ed
Murray telling him that tell you
goon Alice the Goon
dog oh my God dad show up to the show
I'm he I'm ad of Dad okay yeah the [__]
out here bu
CD Wow h on stop the [__] line we're
talking for a half hour now dude oh man
we had they had a beach party they had a
beach party but one of those wannabe Las
Vegas poop parties I was thinking the
same thing dog but it got packed man oh
dude we couldn't even find a seat no
place in Brooklyn where I can hang my
head it was so packed man and it there
were charge in the locals 20 bucks to
get in yeah F [__] them [__] that yeah I
wouldn't go pay 20 bucks 20 bucks to get
in you know they got to charge you for
valet parking too oh dude yeah it's all
valet right there valet M and then what
happened at the end of that pool party
well [__] it didn't even last till the
in h the storm came through the storm
came man and and Floridians knows to get
the [__] out of the water when they see
black clouds [__] truck by that [__]
L now we don't know [__] about stores
man mother thefuck are [__] swimming
outside there's a [__] cable busted
they're [__] swimming next to it and
the thing is like what I heard out here
where I used to live is like um when the
thunderstorms come in there's lightning
rods fool so that's where the Lightning
goes and what the [__] they don't have
that [__] in
Florida they have it over there man they
have to right dude there there's a lot
of lightning storms in Florida they they
know to get out of the water cuz you're
going to die once that lightning rod
hits the water you're dead it happened
in Venice Beach they [__] fried a
couple people fried a kid he was surfing
right next to where the by the pier and
the the lightning hit the water right
there by the pier and he happened to be
around it he got shocked died instantly
oh dude that [__] [__] is a mad Force
do nothing to be [__] [__] with
it's funny how water H lightning hits
water and then if you're near it you're
dead yeah travels right same thing is
like we know when you [__] you want
to I mean not that I've ever tried to
murder anybody but they're in the
[__] bathing or something you [__]
throw in the toaster or [__] curling
iron that works I don't know if it works
let try it ah dick he said get an
extension C but even that I seen in the
movies yeah that's what I've seen the
movies I always see I always think okay
if I do this is it really going to [__]
the whole power up for the house it
could have a power surge I mean who
knows though that was suck huh [__] it
who there's been a lot of accidents too
like that how [__] dropped the
radio yeah that [__] slips in there fool
[__] blow dryer oh dude not even dog I
don't be like that fool what happened oh
man the [__] died what happened
oh the F dropped his vape
pen I was taking dabs with
Jesus oh man we met some cool ass people
in the [__] um at the at the at the
comedy club we met Diego yeah he was
cool the Columbia Columbian guy he was
our our waiter immigrant immigrant man
this guy real immigrant the colia this F
walked from Colombia with his mom to
huras his father was killed by by um by
col by Pablo escovar Rivals well his
rival or his right-hand man right that
one guy you mentioned yeah um his dad
was friends with Poe which was um Paulo
Escobar's um rightand man and he's still
in prison and um he's one of the guys in
that show in that movie um the Escobar
show the narcos M he's he one of he one
of his henchmen he's one of the guys
that Pablo Escobar told him kill your
girlfriend yeah and he killed his lady
he killed his lady yeah man
yeah man those fools are hardcore fools
and that's when all that [__] went down
that's when a lot of Colombians [__]
came North huh cuz all that [__]
Bloodshed dude did they ever even get
political um Asylum they got political
Asylum eventually he said they had to
walk from Colombia through South America
all the way to Honduras and then cross
that little border where everybody from
Central America crossed by bise to
Honduras that one Little River
where everybody crosses there it's like
you can't stop it he said he got in a in
a tire he got in a tire yeah crossed and
then they attached the Rope he's a real
wet bag he said and then they in Mexico
they his mom paid somebody off to put
him in a plane and then fly to the US
yes and you know obviously before it was
all hardcore to you know to get in here
in the 80s and [__] so but now it's
hardcore [__] difficult dude but
anyways shout out to Diego shout out to
Diego and also the other fool that from
Glendale that was they working yeah the
tall I forgot his name George
Lopez it's huh like it be a fat for or
skinny for or a media for be having that
little George Lopez face huh
yeah it's funny always think like okay
my my immigrant story is Hardcore but
that one's hardcore like nobody nobody
killed my dad to come over here but hey
but when you're [__] when they're
after your par it's like um The
Immigrant story now for people from
Salvador and Colombia and wherever
there's like a a Military Coupe or
wherever there's um a drug war or or
terrorist War war Civil War it kind of
like if you look at their story the way
the reason they're coming to America
because they're fighting they're
escaping death or a war if you really
think about it right think about um his
story um Diego story he told us it ain't
different from The Godfather story no CU
they wanted to kill his father they
wanted to kill little little Don coron
they were escaping the the vendettas of
the Cilan Mafia yeah and that's also
same [__] Bro a whole surge Sicilians
were coming over here dude that's when
they were all flooding down Island they
were getting wiped out of the face of
the Earth these Sicilians yeah fool it's
just a mad Bloodshed dude what are you
going to do you're going to stay there
and get killed or you going to creep to
America and [__] create a better life
for you and they sent him by himself F
like a little be himself yeah that fool
that's why that fool was so strong dog
think about so that's why now when
people in guala Nicaragua they're
sending kids that little too huh yeah
there're some you know parentless kids
dog that's crazy H like hey man you know
whato you're going to die here as a
soldier you're going to be a drug dealer
they're going to rape you they're going
to sell you or you're going to just take
your chances and go with your aunt in
Mexico and that's other thing those
countries is where they'll [__] shoot
you in their head and it's not the same
here they're not going to do an
investigation none of that [__] it's
like the three or four days till you
[__] start riding on the street they
don't give a [__] they'll bury your ass
they won't even give you a proper burial
so what's up for um I heard that the the
the favas in neighborhood esina T has
won eight gold medal this
are you serious now made that up but I
know right now the Brazilian the
Brazilian Olympics going down um Lisa
and I have not watched one game I just
seen it last night real quick a a
swimming thing but it's funny it's like
it's all Rodrigo had the best joke by
the way okay this guy said he said it on
Friday he said yeah America just won a
gold medal in shooting yeah the first
gold medal we won is the shooting you
know what I'm saying please we're proud
of that [__] yeah do bullseye yeah man
and she shoot the right
people and um but I dude the thing is
with the Olympics is the same thing when
poit when they have the elections
everybody gets all involved H gets their
little American flags show lazy ass up
dog I just seen it a little bit like the
other night just cuz I was out you know
on another date and we're just watching
it right there on the TV on [__] at
the art house but anyways yeah
everybody's all into it now huh who
gives a [__] dog that's funny man
whenever that there an an Olympics in
any country they try to dig out all the
celebrity they can find from that
country I mean any traces of blood hell
yeah do like I don't care where you go
every time you men Brazil they always
mention Pelle yeah always always
Argentina Maradona Maradona also um I
did radio with Ron and Paul shout out to
Paul and Ron from Fort Lauderdale
showing me a lot of love on the radio
show these gu put me on for an hour bro
that's the first time you've been with
them too no SEC third time oh the first
time Ralphie May hooked it up oh that's
what's up and I a story about and then
the second time I was there with ply
short bro they let me stay with PA short
is it like the one yeah he had like oh
no you had sent me a picture that one
time he was Dr like on theme FL yeah
with that little that little know bro
what's his style what's what happened to
that fool dog I don't know man he got
hit by a brick or something dude timy
partying with the weasel bro man I
follow him I follow him on Snapchat is
it bizarre it's bizarre dude it's like
it's like um I got a story his Snapchat
should be
called how he's like the Snapchat his
poly Shore Snapchat should be called one
snapshot away from being
punched he gets too a little too in
there huh I like like don't be fing my
Asian
daughter hey buddy where you going there
little girl like that you like sushi
like that you're lying F no dog um hey
that one time we went to Peoria fo they
had him there at the club like two weeks
before a week before and he took the
dude with him to the uh after the show
they went back to the hotel right and
paully Shore got mad at him because he's
mad at who at the the dude that was
ushering him around cuz he's all you're
going to get us some chicks right buddy
yeah yeah I'll try we'll see what we can
get so they go back to the hotel
chickless and that fool snaps he showed
us the video where's the [__] chicks
man he got on man he's like Jesus what
do you want me to do go buy some and he
got he went off on his ass like he gets
L laid all the time right after shows he
does you know what he you know what he
does bro he follows 48-year old woman
who know who he is right they were all
into son-in-law like yeah dud like a
48-year old ex heavy metal hot chick ex
hot chick too though talk usually
they're hot but they're
48 a hot 48 they wanted they always
wanted like they still wearing the
[__] Judith pre shirt or Bon Joie
shirt and they're still fing for the hey
buddy
BR the one fun Snapchat that paully sh
had he met this uh this hillbilly couple
after a show over there he was doing
somewhere away from the city by the way
Buffalo Buffalo dog that [__] couple
drove him to manh hat and dropped them
off that's like three hour four hours so
they had like hey buddy on the back seat
bro to the whole drive and they sto at
gas stations and po sh was doing his um
snapshat with people and they were
hanging out with people you could tell
people say man we made a wrong decision
here hey I I I give this to my fans they
love Philipe SP but they don't want to
be in a car for 3 hours with
me I don't want to be in a car with 3
hours with someone that just met think
about it D that this probably short he
probably G 100% of his standup time on
stage did like 45 minutes killed it
right in in his way and they got to see
ply they got to see the weasel and they
took photos with him right they got to
reminisce a little bit of their
childhood like of the spring break cuz
that's what you get when you go see a
show like poly Shore someone you grew up
with you get nostalgic reminiscing like
when we we saw Dice Man how badass was
that hey that was badass I still got the
Goosebumps and dude that [__]
killed it though dog it was even packed
he destroyed F he destroyed he Fu he
brought that [__] douche back on stage
come on man you trying to get laid with
that [__] sweater you
[__] me don't even wear those
sweat he broke down his haircut yeah he
F the wholey that oh dude his friend and
all look at you're hang with MOS who
look like you and they the same haircut
but they were sad remember police
teaching them how to
walk that was a great show it was
[__] great it was so great he didn't
want to hang out with the after no he
did but we had a wait but we're like
[__] it we're not going to wait we're
going go smoke out with some [__]
what the [__] there [__] toding his
back remember we and then we hung out
with some his opener some unknown to
have weed talking about he does better
than him in the road where you at now
that's one thing and open should never
say for you should never say man and the
weed wasn't that good cuz we would have
remembered if if um if you're the opener
even if you're you open for me if you
open for anybody and everybody say Hey
you were the funniest hey man just take
us a grain of salt say thank you very
much and that's it man don't go
everybody man cuz as soon as you tell
somebody it gets back to the other guy
and guess what you're not back on the
road for being a [__] and I and
I've seen I've seen those dudes myself
personally have said that dude and you
know now they're killing somewhere in
the obscurity of uh show business you
know they they're um getting called from
Anam Murray hey man what's going
on hey F I was going to tell you a story
about paully Shore dude that me and
franker one time we uh Seena he had like
an hour special or something dog but
dude oh that one joke dude t
dude I don't think he's he's cool fool
you know as a personality but I don't
think he's hilarious but he has out
there yeah oh he's on the road all the
[__] constant he's on something too
like he has to a medication or something
dude dude this nobody's that soft and
nice this fool had a funny ass joke he's
like yeah bro yeah buddy he's uh yeah
I'm going to adopt a chick buddy like a
girl from like Switzerland buddy and
then like I'm going to adopt her when
she's like 15 bro and I'mma to feed her
that way she can get like a good body
and everything thing and have like a
healthy body and then when she turns 18
I'm going to [__] her
bro me and franker were on her [__]
knees for like two hours dying that's
his material though yes fo it's weird
like like it's a and he gets on the
stool and then I'm going to [__] it
bro we were dying
dog I didn't think it was that funny dog
but that [__] was funny to me even
though no it's [__] [__] F I love
stupid
[__] he was a bon short did a show was
and I heard it was charging women to
sign their boobs and they were pain [__]
he $20 I'll sign your boobs God damn I
want
to it's either a con man or a
businessman but he's raking in the dough
you know who at the at the San Jose
Improv the waiter told me that this
other waiter he kep the prime Stak yeah
the prime rib it wasn't done dude like
it wasn't done he ordered a bunch of
them though yeah but he ate two of them
yeah and then the third one like he I
guess he likes prime rib he [__]
hurled the plate with the steak on Adam
and it hit the
wall and he's like yeah what' you do
well I picked up all the pieces of the
plate and I took it back to the kitchen
had him redo it [__] crazy huh
[__] weasel ain't that soft sometimes
Bro Look at that what you do somebody
throw your steak at you bro on hey man
are you going to let me eat it [__] it
dog what are you going do [__] [__]
it I don't know they don't have a PO
short story dog and I'm going to [__]
her bro and then I'm when she turns 18
on her birthday I'm a [__]
bro horny ass full still hop horny
assful dude wonder if he takes pills dog
it's he has to it's funny D cuz like
he's like 50 something right he has he
has to be pushing 60 dog M sure follow
like these young little blonde white
girls like like hey man Airport in the
airport hey little blondies where you
guys going you got follow me to follow
you
guys and he's following them all the way
to they're ordering food like in their
face [__] dude I'm follow that you can't
get away with that your black dog in
your no you can't get away with that if
you're big yeah you to be soft looking
yeah you have to be a petite fool yeah
dude a slender [__] a size six
yeah in shoes what would you do that
like if you're l sure he say nobody say
stop right maybe they think he's [__]
around but if he cross the line dude I
have to snatch him up real quick
dog yeah that's probably all right
weirdo get away from here and get on his
fight I follow him on Snapchat dude and
it's funny though he like an assistant
as Asian and real tiny real small dude
and this all none the stuff I'm saying
I'm making it up because I saw in his
Snapchat and and I follow him but um he
loves Chinese food Sou Chinese soup I
don't know what kind of one soup but he
has the guy show up to a house cut up
the
vegetables wash all the vegetables cut
up the P the noodles for ited steam it
make it fresh and serve it in his
Chinese bowl that he brings for him and
it's perfect every time po Shore loves
that soup damn always always showing it
like a Prince huh yeah man if you if you
have um a chef he makes soup bro bring
him cuz I remember Willie Bara was going
to hire me to personally make him make
him Chiles wherever he goes your famous
chilak kiles dog that's what want he
cooks better than Gan
Bro [__] okay give her the
recipe yeah man the famous chilas I
haven't tasted those in a while by the
way yeah man I spoke to my mom bro
ah to New York that's cool dog my mom's
all happy bro she's still resting from
New York yeah we were [__] just
walking around everywhere we're just
[__] moving dude it was cool new had
like 35,000 steps bro in three days Fu
did you count did you see your your
little meter I had like 60,000 damn we
walked a lot n f but we locked a lot dog
we walked a lot I grew an extra
toe you
evolved Yeah man so what's up fool man
chilling dog what's up F this week we're
going to be with
um Mike G Latino Comedy Jam in tucon
Arizona man I haven't been a Tucson
Arizona since the Last Comic Standing
tour are you serious no you did a little
one nighter Tucson couple years ago is
that the little theater yeah okay that
right that show was crazy dog that the
theater where that dude shows up our
buddy what's his name that smokes us out
AAR Fabian Fabian yeah when that big old
chick would leave me alone shout out to
Fabian oh that big old girl told you you
told that girl I have a boy I have a
girlfriend and I was like yeah I don't
know that never met [__] this woman all
like d like just go along with the story
dog I don't want to be over here with
this [__] monstrosity dude Jesus
Christ man that [__] kept a real bro she
knew she didn't have a chance with you
so she said [__] I'm going make her
sandwich and Stu yeah she went into
touching all the [__] like dude oh she
grabbing [__] and [__] putting in her
mouth eating chicken wings spitting out
bones oh my God who the [__] does that
dude Yeah man so what's all with your
lady bro nothing chilling fol she had a
baby or what she has a kid a little
child she live with herself WR with her
folks but her mom raising it huh no she
is dude they are you know me the parents
helping to raise it that's cool man when
the family gets involved and helps you
man it's a struggle man to live there
though but at least you get help oh yeah
dude a lot of women just say you know
what [__] this my brother just struggled
and live with my [__]
mom when you live with your mom I don't
know and this is a I know by a fact
because I had live with my mom with my
lady for a short period of time that you
just man your mom just tried to
micromanage everything
man that's not how you do it that's not
how I did it
B damn
matala keep it going not let's not break
the cyle I know her dad Liv there too
yeah dude you go there you go there hang
on the living room I haven't over there
a baby no he's he's six he's little you
met the baby already on Halloween yeah
he's cool last year yeah you went trick-
treating together no we showed up there
later after uh I went to go see de tones
this the one that had the baby daddy and
she went back with the baby daddy no she
was she's never been with him since you
know 5 years ago it was an
exboyfriend oh yeah that was it and
she's like your age yeah that's the only
person I ever been that's my age 38 wow
man how old is the baby 86 a girl or a
boy little boy oh [__]
junor you give him a little [__]
exterminator suit
bro n come on little a little fake one
bro out of a 2 L
bottle killing me over
here teach them bro teach him early
dog he could [__] tell Pops to go to
work give that F some Hees dog it's
[__] see Mando bro [__]
bootlegging the Jennifer Lopez Cher yeah
I talked to that yesterday what the
[__] c yeah take shorty out cuz if
she's not happy nobody's
happy they had fun though dog had drinks
and [__] yeah man it's good to have fun
man it's better to have fun and go have
a show and have a gig there too though
oh hell yeah cuz then you feel like
you're leaving those empty Pockets oh
yeah dude accomplishing some [__] dude
so yeah man I I
audition what check this out man I had
an a lot of auditions I get are always
when I'm out out of town you know and I
got to tape myself and it's always tough
because I'm lazy and I push it off and I
have like um I don't know if you guys
feel this way like you try to do
something and you fail you try it over
and over you keep failing to the point
where you tell yourself you know what
why I keep doing this man they don't
want me I keep [__] this up they
don't want me but um after submitting
aund better like 50 tapes and
auditioning for over a 100 times for a
row I was in um Orlando I'm sorry I was
in Orlando I was in West Palm Beach with
Rodrigo and
Adam and we're already packing our
clothes to go home um Adam wasn't really
packing he was just putting his stuff
back in the
hamper just ping everything gonna leave
till no dude so all we'll get to what
what I anyway so we're getting ready who
packed and um I said hey man let's film
my tape for the
audition because when you when you when
you um self tape it has to be waste up
they got to see your face and they don't
want to see the audition paper so we I
practice I practice all night the night
before and then I said man let me borrow
some of your clothes from this hamper
and I kid you not some of those clothes
were still wet oh I dude I knew that
[__] was musty dog it was musty because
they he didn't I guess he was excited to
go on a trip that he didn't let it fully
dry and that's a little stench that you
get yeah I smelled something dog I don't
try to act like I'm [__] I mean they
were clean clothes but you know like
they didn't dry perfectly all the way so
now
AC so I did the uh the self tape I I
took notes from Rodrigo and Adam and
guess what people I got the roll yeah
man that's a tough we're just going to
figure out scheduling and we'll see
what's up man congratulations do it's
all done yeah so yeah man so look out
for me on that show Superstore [__] yeah
dude I'm already thinking like I'm I'm
already thinking like most actors who
get a co-star and roll like [__] FR
ster I'm already thinking like FR ster
before I even get to the [__] Studio
I'm already thinking like FR ster yeah
man they're going to spin me off
bro yeah bro this [__] character is
[__] is strong
bro I'm going spin off off this [__] you
going be the Breakaway star hell yeah
man I'm going to be a real curing Ro bro
that would be [__] awesome I'm R
right they're going to bring me back for
the Christmas show bro and I'mma pass
out these tainted brownies hanging out
with the reindeer and [__] yeah oh yeah
man I could see it man hey you have to
have Vision fool I'm going to be hanging
around bro with with
Nico at lunch parties oh dude [__] a
dude but that's cool bro I got it [__]
yeah dude all that [__] hard work
pays off I felt it bro when I did the
last line bro I this is the one bro [__]
yeah dude that's what's up dude yeah so
I got I have another audition now so now
now that I got this audition I feel
confident now you're on a roll yeah I'm
going to roll every time I sit
down um Al also great news man I don't
know if you guys heard but Jo Diaz got
his blue belt yeah I heard bro you know
what I'm saying [__] tapping out for
the world over there bro and blue luck
yeah it was a big old [__] spectacle
huh I guess it's a big thing to get your
blue belt you know move is that close to
Black Belt well I guess they got blue
what else they got brown and then black
or purple purple what's the order yellow
white white yellow White's the first one
GRE yellow blue white yellow green I
think blue oh wait there's orange too
orange you're right there red also is it
red only in karate yeah I don't even
know about that shitu yeah yeah I think
it's black I think it's black purple
blue brown Orange it's black brown yeah
purple yeah and then blue don't
know I don't know man I got I want to
know that I'm wearing a brown bout right
now we got Rodrigo here looking it up
and [__] yeah all right what is
it um what the the [__] do we got all
right dude what's it [__]
say color bels or that's right [__] suck
a [__] blue Bel that's that's how you
need to know stripes and degrees I've
been working very hard on this bro
little Stripes huh Star General Fu dude
I don't know all
dude images okay all right what we got
we got white gray yellow orange green
and then you got senior rank blue purple
brown black and then you got the degrees
all right then you got Reds I mean [__]
it's crazy I don't [__] know dude but
I guess yeah and then you got the little
degrees I think right the Middle s like
a pyramid
scheme yeah full [__] they make money
off that [__] but it's all good so I'm
working on my health Filipe you know
what I'm saying I want to see the little
[__]
graduate remember when he was saying
he's doing jumpy Jacks and [__] when the
baby was when what's her name was first
pregnant it's cool though dude yeah man
what's up fool man what's up dog we have
another shout out man another shout out
here man this is
a a sad one a sad one uh one of our
listeners passed
away um he was a friend of ours we we
met this guy anyway so we'll read it
first ultimate shout out goes to our
brother our friend our loyal listener
and Super Fan Rory Hillman who passed
away last week while driving his semi at
work he was in a major accident in
Washington and passed away he leaves
behind his fiance Rebecca and his four
daughters man this guy right here we met
him the first time Richland Richland
Washington that it was an awesome show I
remember I remember the whole weekend of
this show because we stood in these
hotel rooms that looked that there were
the best hotels they had during
1966 when the Rat Pack went there I know
man put it this way man back then when
they will spend tons on money on on
curtains these [__] curtains were
[__] thick and no sun they blocked
everything hell yeah it was it could be
2: in the afternoon 100° outside inside
a hotel room was 60 and it felt like
midnight hell yeah dude it was Pitch
Black um that was a day that um Flo
almost died oh he wanted to go party
dog as soon as we land this fool goes to
the hospital and misses the first show
he
did he misses the first show and he
didn't tell us that he's not supposed to
fly with his condition yeah he didn't
tell us first of all and Rory our our
fan who passed away he came because he
had heard Flo on our podcast so thought
he was funny so he wanted to see
Flo so that day um Rory and his wife
Rebecca show up and they have like a
camper truck and um um Rodrigo was
talking to them at the end of their
show at and um Roo hits me up he goes
bro this dude [__] has dabs dog in
his truck and I said shut up impossible
yeah and like good D and
impossible so we go to his car not only
does he has dabs this food makes two
types of Seviche yeah his lady made it
Rebecca his wife Rebecca made um shrimp
ciche for us and it was like good shrimp
ciche and she knew that I was vegan and
she made um vegan ciche which was all
vegetables vegetarian saiche vegetarian
saiche and he was telling us how how
much he loved the show and
he's a big fan he heard me on the on J
Diaz podcast and bu in the Beast so he's
been like a big time listener we hung
out with him and when I went to do a
show in Boise
Idaho this food drove with his um
brother to go check out the show and he
dabbed us out over there hell yeah dude
this food don't care bro this for dab in
a hotel room the back of the kids room
it don't even
matter so that was another time he
showed up then um San Jose Improv he
showed up yeah dude episode and at the
100 episode at the ice house they flew
over he flew with his wife that was
their vacation that was that that fool
made a v our podcast show of
vacation because they got to go to The
Comedy Store and saw Joe Diaz Joe Rogan
but our podast our 100 episode imagine
bro
you you and we made fun of them at the
show like your wife looks at you you're
talking to your wife honey where you
want to go to Vacation you want to go to
Hawaii you want to go to New York you
want to go to
Chicago you want to go to Mexico where
you want to go Disneyland Six Flags
Universal where you want to go you know
where I want to go I want to go to
Pasadena
California are you [__] serious
what's in Pasadena California Rodrigo CH
and Filipe bar is a 100th episode of the
what so F podcast it's on Wednesday we
show up there on Monday we go to The
Comedy Store improv so they had like a
comedy tour yeah dude that food love
comedy I think his last comedy show was
Ralphie May yeah dude he was all dude
into the podcast just into what we were
saying and just super cool [__]
dog like for real dude cuz it's you know
there's people that come around or
whatever it's like with no weed yeah and
it's you're not but he was just
authentically cool dog never want he
never asked for free tickets no and it's
and that's the thing dude it's like dude
[__] always coming all free
it's like dude what the [__] dude dude
what are you going to ask the [__]
phone company to give you a [__] free
phone bill dude or it's like dude just
over there with the [__] hands open
all the time but he was really [__]
cool and they always [__] uh showed
his mad love dude and he knew every
detail of the podcast like [__] right
away he's like oh what's the name of
[__] Chuck Norris dog you know what I
mean it's like Miss A Beat dude and when
it goes he he came up to me one time he
goes hey man I'm sorry you lost Chuck
Norris your hamster yeah dude cuz he
knew I was sad and
um him wife love inela that CER podcast
and they knew that when Lisa was
pregnant and then she had a miscarriage
and lost a baby they they gave us a card
and they made Lisa a bracelet little
baby feet a little a little bracelet
with baby feet yeah man he didn't have
to do all that but that's how much they
were into it and they're just like just
really authentic people dog you know um
so when when they were here in La he had
the the the dab rig and all that right
and the vape pen
and he's [__] hit it bro in Marina
del re he hit it in Marina del re man
and it was like a scavenger hunt you
know it was like a scavenger
hunt yeah he sent me a map on where to
find a rig and a dab you know my stupid
ass rrio call this fool where is it at
dog [__] hit the little thing right
there all right d go between the bushes
between the street and that I found it
dog all right cool [__] but yeah dude
and then he's just cool like that it's
like and you know how [__] are
with weed you gots that are just cheap
dog that'll [__] give you a couple
hits off the blunt and then go turn it
on really [__] and it's just
like I just to me those people always
but this fool was cool dog this really
and he a cool white boy dog you I mean
and not the [__] white boys ain't
cool funny [__] he's like the
ultimate mlo yeah you go to his photos
they're at a [__] rodeo with a bunch
of bisas he the only white boy there
yeah and having fun dog it to it didn't
matter dog he had a lot of like he had a
lot of different type of friends bro not
just white asian Indian fools yeah dud a
lot of Mexican friends but they love
that food
yeah yeah they love that food F they
started to e fund me for him and the it
started at they only wanted five grand
and within 12 hours
that [__] we preed in a lot of money too
that [__] Rose from 5,000 to 18,000
25,000 it's up to
25,000 he was the Sole Provider for four
girls yeah man this guy he was a Sole
Provider for his four daughters he has
two daughters that were his and two
daughters that came in with a
relationship and um this guy was the
only worker like his mom his wife did um
arts and crafts you know little dresses
for girls little ribbons but this guy
drove a truck and he had a had a weed
farm yeah F was like a very hardworking
give him a little
honk hell yeah f um also man um you know
dude on
Facebook some woman that was there she
said um hey um I'm so sorry for your
loss my husband was there when um when
um Rory ran off the road and she said
that her husband risked his life to go
take him out of the truck and he took
him out of the truck man that's to every
call and he listened to he called into
to every calling show on the ball just
like that lady Mar
Soul so we're going to play some clips
of him calling into the show he always
called in and said what's up
fool shout out to Rory Hill man two of
us that's crazy man like you leave four
daughters behind and it's crazy man
because um when you're on the road like
a like a father or a mother like who's
always on the road and always working
and um they die on the road you always
have that feeling that they're going to
come home like is they going to come
home like one of her comments were come
home Daddy that's
sad so also to our big shout out to our
other truck driver who's out there that
big [__] I don't know your name
that full in the midwest the 510 X guy
also for every anybody out there who's
doing a lot of traveling this summer on
the road and you see a big ass truck in
front of you don't cut him off you're
not just cutting him off you're cutting
off a family member from his family
that's trying to get home so be safe out
there man um be reasonable and um don't
be in a hurry to die you know let
somebody don't flip be be nice on the
road cuz you don't know who's on the
front of you you know [__] no there's
room for for everybody man the room for
everybody man and we're all going to get
there man we're all going to get to our
destination we don't have to hurry up
you know uh maybe you know just be more
Curious on the road when you're driving
out there man cuz you never know who's
out there and um I know Rory you're over
there listening to us man and I know you
loved our standup and you loved our St
our podcast and we love you too man and
yeah man we're going to miss you we're
going to miss you calling in and we're
going to miss you a little honk man I
was devastated when you show me the news
it was [__] sad he [__] up
dog so man
um we we love every listener we have
yeah all you guys we do this podcast for
you guys you know we give everybody a
shout out when we can you know and um
thank you for listening man thanks for
listening and um [__] we'll see you guys
in two weeks it be cool be
cool